let's go next to Jeremy from Chicago
Jeremy also a member at davidpackman.com
Jeremy I very much appreciate that
Jeremy you've muted yourself for some
reason I would love for you to unmute
yourself then you'll be able to talk to
me
oh hi can you hear me I can hear you yes
nice awesome cool
um so yeah um I I'm a member of your
show and yeah one of the reasons for
that besides the award-winning bonus
show which you make so much money off of
is the soundboard and
the soundboard is so freaking hilarious
and I really appreciate it thank you I
appreciate that
I question about the sound board is
besides Obama and Truth Central right
what are your favorite sounds in the
sound board the uh the the technical
glitches when Trump does speeches and
the audio goes haywire and it frustrates
Trump or probably some of my favorite
ones also Trump trying and failing to
pronounce Indian names while he was in
India at a speech those have got to be
pretty near the top for me
that's for sure because I I think I
emailed you about adding more sounds to
the soundboard yes and we will do that
we're continuing to expand it
awesome awesome
um one more question
um Trump in 2024 assuming that he wins
the 2024 election do you think that he
will
um find a way to
extend his presidential life no to
like not even 2028 no
like I'm just trying to like
ask this question in terms of like is it
I don't see him like
um
I think I know where you're going with
this you we don't it's hard to imagine
him leaving calmly and quietly if Trump
wins in 2024 he'll be inaugurated in
January 2025 and he will leave in
January 2029. I do not believe that he
is going to do anything to try to get
himself a third term
Phil
yeah like do you think he will like this
sounds this sounds so crazy but like
like trying to over rule or repeal the
22nd amendment no because I don't think
so
have yeah no I don't think he's going to
do that I think he'll do his uh his his
years five through eight and then he'll
leave
you know she is leaning into
dictators like poon and president XI
from China and so like I don't know
that's my assumptions that she wants to
stay present for as long as he wants yep
no I I think he's dangerous in a lot of
ways he tried to steal the election in
2020 but I think four more years at the
most is what we will have from Trump all
right Jeremy from Chicago great to hear
from you very much appreciate it let's
go next to Andrew from Massachusetts
Andrew from Massachusetts welcome to the
program what's going on
hi David can you hear me yes
so uh my question is related to the pbd
podcast and I'm actually halfway through
the Lex Friedman interview okay uh and
thoughts about something that Lex said
about your appearance on the pbd podcast
so Lex suggested that while you and
Patrick probably have some disagreements
that many of Patrick's arguments with
you during that podcast were kind of
your conservative Playing devil's
advocate to bring out the best in you do
you recall him saying that I recall him
saying that yeah
okay so I think that's a pretty
charitable take yeah
yeah so I'm wondering what you think
about that
um especially given that I don't know if
you've heard that uh Patrick made a 100
million dollar offer to Tucker this was
obviously before he announced um he was
going to Twitter yeah but wondering if
you've heard about the 100 million
dollar offer and then I did so here's
the thing here's the thing Andrew
Patrick Bet David is a trump guy okay I
don't know how much I don't watch all of
his episodes by any means but it's very
clear he's a trump guy you know we
talked a little bit behind the scenes
like he's a trump guy that and that's
totally fine he's not like he doesn't
seem like an unhinged social
conservative although he sort of seems
to be delving into the trans stuff a
little bit but I think mostly for
economic reasons he kind of likes the
Trump stuff so when Lex Friedman said
that he thought a lot of what Patrick
was doing was just playing Devil's
Advocate I didn't agree but the thing
especially in a three and a half hour
interview like when I was on the Lex
Friedman show is I can't argue about
everything I disagree with and the call
I'm made as the interview was going on
was it doesn't make sense to kind of
stop the flow to argue about whether pbd
was Playing devil's advocate because Lex
wasn't actually there he watched it and
it's based on my recollect it wouldn't
have been an interesting place to kind
of like get into it if that makes sense
so that's why sometimes you just kind of
have to let things go in order to get to
something that you think might be more
interesting or substantive
all right thanks for the clarification
uh that's that's all I really had today
all right thanks there's Andrew from
Massachusetts uh with a question about
my discussion with Lex Friedman about my
appearance with Patrick Bet David both
of either of which I would be glad to do
again
let's go to Samantha from Philly
Samantha from Philly welcome to the
David packman show what's on your mind
today
hey David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
um I really enjoy the show and I enjoy
when you talk about polling okay and
was how does polling take into
consideration
specifically voting voting on issues I
guess and voting just politically
biasedness what do you mean
so I guess what I'm getting to is how
does how does pulling taken to
consideration new population trends that
haven't emerged yet as voters per se but
they will so you might so like an
example would be
if right now in May of 2023 you're doing
a poll of Texas voters about how they
plan to vote and if you are normalizing
the sample based on the 2022 data for
example about gender and race and age
and all these different things but it
turns out for example that like by
2024's election there will be more
Latino voters and so you actually need
to account for that in your methodology
is that sort of what you're asking
that's exactly right it could be any
sort of demographic that explodes in the
next election but hasn't yet the answer
is basically there's two versions of the
answer and both are kind of right one is
different polls account for that in
different ways and if you read the
methodology page they will usually tell
you how they are how they are picking
their sample and adjusting their sample
and then you can look and say oh this
poll is adjusting the sample in a way
that does make sense and this one is
doing it in a way that doesn't the other
perspective will be
there's rarely polling done so far in
advance that the demographic changes
will be so big that they'll make more
than like a point of difference and so
like I actually think in many cases I
don't know offhand whether my my example
was the Latino population in Texas will
grow and Latino voters tend to vote
other than Cubans they tend to vote more
for Democrats than Republicans my guess
is even without accounting for what the
Latino population will be in November of
24 that the difference between now and
then isn't going isn't so significant
that you that you are going to be way
off if you don't account for the change
and use today's numbers that would be my
statistical guess
do you feel that the polling was
accurate before the that you've seen for
the midterms
uh I think it was well you know it's a
good question I think the problem with
that polling you know I'd have to review
it I don't remember the the polling
generally said the most likely scenario
was Democrats keep the Senate and lose
the house and that did happen so in that
sense it was accurate yeah
yeah
it was accurate in that sense but you
know I don't know if the reporting is
just sensationalized but you know
everyone said it's historical the
numbers are historical we didn't see
this coming you mean the red wave that
they predicted would have been historic
or that what actually happened is
historic what happened was historic oh
it's unusual certainly I mean democrats
should have done way worse than they did
but particularly in the two months
before the midterms the polling did
pretty closely reflect what ultimately
happened
okay well all right great that was my
question all right Samantha from Philly
thank you very much let's take just the
quickest of breaks we're going to keep
talking to people who are waiting uh so
so hang on if you're waiting to talk to
me we'll take a very quick break and
then be right back